Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous l'attendiez tous, aujourd'hui,
on parle de la sauce préférée
des français : la mayonnaise.
Essayez de mélanger
de l'eau et de l'huile,
vous verrez, c'est impossible.
Et pourtant, pour réaliser une mayonnaise,
c'est exactement ce que l'on fait.
C'est extraordinaire,
au sens propre du terme.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Pourquoi la mayonnaise prend-elle ?
Allez, suivez-moi, ça tourne.
Les français adorent la mayonnaise.
Hmm, c'est bon.
2 français sur 3 affirment en consommer au moins une fois par mois
et 60% en auraient, en permanence,
dans le réfrigérateur.
Il n'est donc pas étonnant
que chaque année,
Paris soit le théâtre d'un championnat du monde qui fleure bon la mayonnaise,
celui de l'œuf mayo,
un plat iconique des bistrots français.
Sans surprise, le titre est détenu depuis
le 14 novembre 2022 par un chef français,
Grégoire Simon, de la Grande Brasserie,
dans le 4ème arrondissement de Paris.
Et maintenant, je vous explique,
comment on fabrique de la mayonnaise.
Vous allez le voir, c'est un véritable miracle.
Avez-vous déjà essayé de
mélanger de l'huile et de l'eau ?
Comme vous pouvez le constater,
l'huile et l'eau ne se mélangent pas.
L'huile est hydrophobe, elle n'aime pas l'eau
et l'eau est lipophobe, elle n'aime pas l'huile.
Très concrètement,
les molécules d'eau se lient entre elles,
les molécules d'huile aussi,
mais les molécules d'eau
et les molécules
d'huile ne se marient pas.
Et, vous aurez beau avoir l'impression
de les réunir,
comme ceci,
en patientant quelques instants, c'est
retour à la case départ :
les 2 liquides sont séparés.
En cuisine, ça arrive très souvent
quand on fait une vinaigrette
sans autres ingrédients,
que du vinaigre et de l'huile.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle une émulsion instable.
Mais quand on fait une mayonnaise
avec un œuf et de l'huile, ça fonctionne.
L'huile et l'eau se mélangent.
Bah, il n'y a pas d'eau
dans ces ingrédients.
Dans l'œuf. Un œuf est constitué
à 95% d'eau.
Mais pourquoi ça prend ?
Eh bien, grâce aux 5%
restants : des lipoprotéines.
Ce sont elles
qui vont jouer les agents de liaison
entre l'huile et l'eau
contenue dans l'œuf.
En chimie,
on parle de tensioactif ou d'émulsifiant.
Ces tensioactifs sont des molécules
un peu particulières.
On les représente souvent, comme ceci,
avec une tête hydrophile
qui aime l'eau, et une queue lipophile qui aime l'huile.
Pour que ça marche, pensez toujours
à sortir l'œuf du réfrigérateur
un bon quart d'heure,
avant de vous y mettre,
de sorte, qu'il soit à température ambiante.
Tiens, j'en profite
pour ouvrir une petite parenthèse :
où faut-il ranger les œufs ? où faut-il les stocker,
dans le réfrigérateur
ou à température ambiante ?
Eh bien, selon
une étude récente de l'EFSA,
l'Autorité Européenne de Sécurité des Aliments, il vaut mieux les stocker au frais.
Cette précaution limite,
en effet, la croissance des bactéries
et donc le risque d'infection.
Mais, revenons à notre mayonnaise.
Quand on la bat, on fragmente
l'huile en petites gouttelettes
pour faciliter les liaisons entre l'huile
et les tensioactifs.
On se retrouve donc, avec une multitude
de petites gouttelettes d'huile,
avec tout autour, des tensioactifs
et autour
une petite pellicule d'eau,
l'eau étant attirée par la tête des molécules,
c'est ce qu'on appelle : une micelle.
Eh bien, dans une mayonnaise,
il n'y a que ça,
des micelles.
C'est pour cette raison qu'il est recommandé
d'utiliser un fouet comme celui-ci
et un grand saladier,
pour faire des gestes amples.
Au passage, je vous conseille d'utiliser un saladier
en verre ou en métal.
Les émulsifiants ont, en effet,
tendance à s'accrocher aux plastiques
et ce n'est pas le moment
quand on fait une mayonnaise.
Parfois,
il arrive que la mayonnaise ait du mal
à prendre ou pire,
qu'elle ne prenne pas du tout.
Ça peut être à cause de l'œuf
pas assez frais.
Attention,
j'ai dit frais, pas froid.
L'œuf doit être à température,
je l'ai expliqué,
mais il ne doit pas être trop vieux.
Plus le temps passe, plus les tensioactifs
contenus dans le jaune se dégradent.
S'il a été pondu trop longtemps
avant son utilisation,
il n'y en a plus assez pour réunir
l'eau et l'huile.
Tient au fait, avec quoi préférez-vous déguster la mayo ?
Dites-le moi en commentaire
et en fin de vidéo,
je vous dirai
quel est mon plat mayo préféré.
Pour faire une mayonnaise,
on utilise aussi de la moutarde.
Une bonne cuillérée ? A quoi ça sert ?
Eh bien, d'abord,
ça donne du goût, mais pas que,
la moutarde contient également
des émulsifiants
qui vont faciliter le rapprochement
entre l'huile et l'eau.
La mayo va prendre plus facilement
mais attention, on n'utilise pas n'importe
quelle moutarde.
Ses molécules se trouvent à l'origine
dans la pellicule
qui enveloppe les graines de moutarde.
Or, dans la moutarde à l'ancienne,
vous le voyez,
il y a encore beaucoup de graines
qui n'ont pas été broyées.
Du coup, les molécules émulsifiantes
n'ont pas été libérées.
Si vous utilisez de la moutarde
à l'ancienne,
vous aurez donc du mal à faire
prendre votre mayonnaise.
Plus de mal
qu'avec une moutarde classique.
En plus, les petites graines
ne sont pas forcément les bienvenues
quand ce que l'on recherche, c'est avant tout
l'homogénéité et l'onctuosité.
Allez, c'est parti !
Et là, il se produit un autre phénomène intéressant,
la mayonnaise prend du volume.
On dit qu'elle monte, c'est encore un phénomène
lié à l'utilisation de la moutarde.
Les molécules émulsifiantes se comportent
comme celles
avec lesquelles on fait de la gelée.
En captant l'eau contenue dans l'œuf
et l'humidité contenue dans l'air,
elles prennent du volume, elles gonflent,
ce qui fait monter la mayonnaise.
Et voilà le travail !
Des centaines de milliers de gouttes
d'huile sont prises
au piège de molécules d'eau qui forment
une fine pellicule tout autour.
Plus le piège est serré, moins
les gouttelettes d'huile peuvent bouger,
plus la mayonnaise est ferme.
Et tient !
Allez,
pour finir,
un tour de poivre, une pincée de sel
et le tour est joué.
Allez, on termine avec un peu d'Histoire.
Qui a inventé la mayo ?
La première trace écrite d'une mayonnaise, telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui, date de 1815.
Elle est signée du célèbre Antonin Carême,
celui que l'on surnomme
le roi des chefs et le chef des rois.
Il parle d'une magnonnaise,
froide émulsionnée au jaune d'œuf.
Carême a inventé de nombreuses recettes,
mais ce n'est pas lui
qui aurait eu l'idée de la mayonnaise.
Elle aurait été inventée en 1756,
durant la guerre de 7 ans.
À cette époque, les armées de Louis XV
sont en guerre contre les Anglais.
Le duc de Richelieu,
cherche à envahir
Mahon, la capitale de Minorque,
une petite île située en mer
Méditerranée au large de l'Espagne.
Etant la plus à l'est des îles de l'archipel des Baléares,
elle a un rôle stratégique et commercial majeur pour les 2 pays.
Richelieu remporte la bataille
et pour fêter sa victoire,
il organise un banquet pour lequel
son cuisinier
aurait inventé une sauce qu'il baptise
en l'honneur de la victoire,
la mahonnaise qui serait devenue
la mayonnaise, avec le temps.
On pense aussi que la mayonnaise
pourrait venir de Magnon
dans le Lot et Garonne ou peut-être de Bayonne.
Magnonnaise ou bayonnaise
se serait peu
à peu transformé en mayonnaise.
Mais l'hypothèse la plus probable reste
que la mayonnaise
vient du vieux français "moyeu"
qui signifiait jaune d'œuf.
Avec le temps,
la moyeunnaise serait devenue
la mayonnaise.
Alors, qu'est-ce que je vais servir
avec cette belle mayonnaise ?
Tout à l'heure,
je vous ai promis de vous révéler
ce que je préfère déguster avec la mayo.
Eh bien, sans hésitation.
Un œuf dur.
L'œuf mayo, j'adore ça.
Il existe même une association
qui défend ce plat : l'ASOM,
l'Association de Sauvegarde
de l'Œuf Mayonnaise,
à laquelle j'ai l'honneur d'appartenir.
La preuve ?
Voici ma carte.
C'est d'ailleurs cette association
qui organise
le championnat du monde de l'œuf mayo
dont on a parlé en début de vidéo.
Voilà,
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
que je vous ai donné
envie de confectionner
vous-même votre propre mayonnaise.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner et à liker.
N'hésitez pas non plus à me suggérer
d'autres idées de plats ou de sauces.
Je vous promets d'autres vidéos,
toutes aussi délicieuses.
Allez, à très bientôt
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.
Qui m'a mis un œuf dur ?